it's a violent Santa Claus movie
Santa Claus is Coming to Town
Santa is very different than anything
you've ever seen like this Santa has
baggage 10 000 years past of him giving
out toys he creates this commercialist
horrible world where kids just want more
and more and more I better get going
presents aren't going to deliver
themselves
Xanax stumbles across his house and if
there's a little girl in there it still
believes in Christmas I still believes
in Santa that is a direct hotline of
Santa Claus himself I can talk to Santa
Trudy you'll always believe in him no
matter what hello Santa
welcome to your worst Christmas ever
Santa Witnesses Trudy in an extreme
situation he has no choice but to act
Santa there's two Batman with guns
watching us are you gonna help us yeah
no my nice list you've been a very good
girl this year it's like two movies one
this crazy die-hard trapped in a house
burst scenaries Vault underneath 300
million dollars and then you have
Miracle on 34th Street movie and they
just sort of like smashed together
Julie's trying to help Santa to get his
Christmas spirit back it kind of just
warms your heart they're naughty
one I give my lump a call give them
their lumps
[Music]
it's all you can eat Byron's Gore
hilarity might be the real Santa
really touching and moving in great
freaking action
my friend Mr Claus please call me Santa